[Musique]
eh bien merci à jean claude brialy à
tous les artistes maison du stress et
frais non non ce n'est pas à vous que je
parle c'est le ministère de l'intérieur
parce que figurez-vous que nous avons
une petite incertitude
vous avez entendu comme nous tout à
l'heure et c'est pour ça je me renseigne
par téléphone monsieur chirac annoncé
une participation de 87 78 % alors que
nous nous indiquons 86 63 63 exclus qui
s'est trompé s nous j'attends avec cette
ligne cuir l'intérieur de le savoir pour
vous le dire mais cela ne nous empêche
pas de regarder le tableau complet
maintenant pratiquement complet du
résultat de ce deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle ce résultat
donne 12 millions 291 1806 voix pour
monsieur françois mitterrand qui obtient
6 49 28% des suffrages exprimés en
métropole et monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing 16 millions 13 millions 160
4886 voir et 50,71 % des suffrages
exprimés
tout de suite je me permets de vous
faire remarquer ce qu'était notre
estimation sofres au rtf 50 80 et là
nous avons 50 71 49 20 et nous avons 49
il était difficile je crois de tomber
plus juste quand on sait quand même
qu'une estimation s'autorise une
certaine marge d'erreur sur la
participation nous annoncions nous 87 40
et le ministère de l'intérieur annonçait
tout à l'heure 86 63 mais monsieur
chirac m'at-il semblé je crois que
d'autres l'ont entendue comme moi à 10
87 78 ce qui d'ailleurs donnerait raison
à notre estimation à l'eau oui oui vous
un temps oui je répète a pour tout le
monde il ya confusion entre le taux de
participation
87 78 oui
ah je vaux j'ai compris j'ai quand même
merci beaucoup merci de te revoir
monsieur
alors voilà c'est bien 87 78 mais le
chiffre qui a été envoyé par erreur
comme celui là participation était celui
des suffrages exprimés ce qui est qu'ils
sont voyez que les blancs et nuls étant
de 1 17
c'est effectivement tout à fait normal
guy môquet 1 17%
donc participation 87 78 % record absolu
de toutes les consultations électorales
en france nous disions nous 87 40
on était un tout petit peu en dessous de
la vérité mais quand même pas loin
blancs et nuls 1,17
je crois que en regardant ces chiffres
on a à peu près le résultat définitif de
cette élection présidentielle qui
indique que monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing a donc été élu aujourd'hui
président de la république française
[Musique]